vous êtes des potentiels suspects à
partir de maintenant quelqu'un essaie de
piéger
tout va bien se passer
ça va mal se passer
on trouve rarement des podcasts de
criminels qui font l'objet tout de suite
une réelle opportunité qui s'offre à
nous est-ce que vous aussi vous croyez
qu'il reste des zones d'ombré à
éclaircir trouvez vous un autre
passeport tant que ça ne nous conduit
pas en prison comme tricoter on cherche
de nouvelles preuves vous savez quelque
chose que vous gardez pour vous le
parjure ça vous dit un truc le jeu
connaît le parjure
j'aligne or nous vivons pas lire les
classes et nous plongeant comme ça vous
n'avez pas envie de laver autre nom
il faut que j'aille au concentrons nous
attendent et vous n'allez pas me planter
là je ne suis pas dans mon élément soit
je n'osais même pas là des inconnus par
peur de passer pour un type louche et
[Musique]
d'épreuves n'arrête pas d'apparaître
dans nos appartements
celui qui a fait ça y est les remontera
du jour
toute nouvelle direction nous espérons
qu'ils nous conduira jusqu'aux à 10
c'est un but
alors que savons-nous sur le meurtre de
ma fille tout est là tu venir vous
pensez que cette femme apprenait rld est
quelqu'un lui
évidemment on va la mettre de côté pour
le moment non
comme vous pouvez voir on y chante
les options s'ouvrent à lui à la
première je vous gifle et la seconde on
passe directement au moment où vous
dites c'était dur à entendre mais j'en
avais besoin je choisi l'option son
génie
nous avons lancé l'opération au lit mais
bof quoi holliday belle forme et de tous
nos prénoms et le charme au lit mais
bell le charles et muet